ελκιστικός και κυρίως ο γεωρκός να έχει δίκαιον και σταθερών ισόδημα το ο στόχος είναι
απεξάρτηση από τις καιρικές υθηκες γιότι οι κύπρος δεν θα μπορεί να καλιερική με όλα
αυτά τα οοία μας λένε οι μελέτες σημερα άραμια πολύ σημααντική βληματική δράσει του τη
στρατιγικής είναι η μελέτη που θα κάνει τοοπανεπιστήμεο κύπρου η οποία αλουσιαστικά θα μας καταδείξει
πώς θα προσαρμοστείς αυτές τις κληματικές συχθήκες η γεωργεία μας σε πιές καλιέργειες πρέπει να
δώσουμε έύφαση και οπός και ότού το αι θα γινηθειοριτικά διλαδε θα μας δώσουν ένα
χαρτήντο να μας που εδώστε έύφαση σε ξηρικές καλλιέργιες βλέπε χαρούπια που το γνωρίζουμε θα
θα καταρτιστεί ολόκληρος ο δικός χάρτης του πός θα γίνει ιδές μεση χρηματοδοδικές δεςμ καιο
τα πλάνω πριακάνον τα σχέδια για να το δούμε αυτός στην περράξει και πως θα
θα περάζεση στον πρωτογενήντομε και αχαλούμεκαι διαπόμενη μέρα στο να μηχάσουμε τολοιπόν το πρότον και
πιο σημαντικόών που χρειάζεται να κάνουν που το μεγάλον πρόπλημα που έχουμε αυτή τη την
περίοτο είναι ι αύξηση του εγώ πρόφλιου γάλα ακτος εμείς έχουμε να ανακοινώσει και έχουμεδώσει
έξωστων στους σεόλους τους ενδιαφερόμενος κοσιέξει κρατικά τμάχεια τα οποία μέσα από απλοποιημένες διαδιγασίας σε
τρεις μήνες μπορεί κάποιος να ξεκινήσει να κατασκεβάζει σύγχρονη επαγγεληματικοί μονάβαν εγώ προγματοτροφίες αυτό είναι
πρώτη φορά που συμβαίνει στην κυπριακή δημοκρατία και ακριβώς εθέλαμε να το κάνουμε τούτον το
πράγμα για να μπορέσουμε να αυξήσουμε των πληθισμό των εγώ προβάτω αλλά να αυξήσουν και
την παραγωγικότα το πρώτον εντούτο ιάμε ο φίλον από ένα μεγάλον ευχαριστώ και στοτημοα γειοργίας
και στο κτηματολόγιον στο τημα κτηματρολογείο και